last few years have been big few and
have involved a lot of transitions so
stand-up comedy and then acting and
acting and then politics and activism
when you're doing all that is it hard to
get back into stand-up headspace
well no not for me we'll eat because I
tell you why because for me all things
must come from a center of truth whether
you're doing this interview here in the
project or doing stand-up comedy or
making love to a fine-looking woman in
hope of a second child do it from the
place in you that is true from the place
that in you is real in some it's from
some ideologies you would call it God or
Allah or Vishnu or whatever but for me
is that essence behind your personal
identity we are connected to greatness
all of us feel it in silence the quiet
voice of wonder present in us all you
can use that comedy you can use it
anywhere even great athletes use it it
was that crazy tennis kid you've got now
he's coming from somewhere deep he's
deep times in your life where you've
lost that you felt like he lost it yes
I lose it every day you get it back in
time for win the show start please God